you get that song nick uh yeah yeah this
[ __ ] is so hard
i want you just i want you to think
you're in the club
your cheeks are out theo your cheeks are
out have you seen craig's news live
don't be scared to turn that [ __ ] up
nick let theo get his cheeks out feel it
which cherry cheeks you want from the
bottom
[Music]
if you ain't thick please don't get
involved don't want them skinny like
models i don't need a girl that look
like she is
cause i need everything dead i'm in the
kitchen like jelly roll whipping my
wrist man you know what it is i've been
getting my weight up to round with the
dick boys
riding around making big noise outta
super thick from my wallet
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
my [ __ ] is super bad and she's thicker
than oatmeal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
start a record label i didn't
yeah ins i of records
well you know we'll call it whatever but
i took the money from our zoo in mexico
and put it into the music
that's why the ostriches didn't get
delivered
modern day sugar night bro look at you
yeah sugar
stevie at night
is